exclusive new insight into the enormous
task of bringing january 6 rioters to
justice we are now one year later from
the assault on the capitol with more
than 725 defendants it is shaping up to
be the largest federal criminal
investigation in u.s history full stop
the top prosecutor who launched the
probe spoke exclusively with our senior
investigative correspondent catherine
herridge
it was important for us to move quickly
to charge a good number of cases to
instill in the public that the rule of
law worked
michael sherwin then the justice
department's top prosecutor in the
district of columbia launched the
capital rights investigation within 10
weeks we're talking about i think close
to a thousand search warrants 13 1500
grand jury subpoenas 350 to 400 arrest
warrants so just a number unseen before
in any probably federal district in
history you said that no one was off
limits everything was on the table it
didn't matter if you were a speaker that
day or if you were a congressman if you
were in the executive office the
president or if you were just one of the
vendors selling popcorn that day if your
conduct fit the crime we had the
evidence you were charged since that day
more than 725 defendants have been
arrested the vast majority charged with
entering or remaining in a restricted
federal building or grounds about 40
defendants including oath keepers three
percenters and proud boys face more
serious conspiracy charges at least five
had pleaded guilty
sherwin told cbs news the trend lines
emerged early
the great bulk of those individuals were
these one-offs
they made terrible decisions this wasn't
something that was pre-baked and planned
and then you have a sliver of cases
we'll call the militia type cases where
there appear to be a more collective
planning the votes for president of the
united states
later that day as then vice president
mike pence certified the electoral
college prosecutors mapped a legal
strategy we initially had a command post
set up that evening at the capitol
police headquarters
where we had to set up an architecture
to handle these cases because there was
no roadmap from an fbi mobile command
center thousands of hours of social
media and security cameras footage
collected often reviewed minute by
minute
we set up crews to look at body worn
camera footage and videos to try to
identify who those people were
identify fix find them and then get
arrest warrants on them
prosecutors say 140 police officers were
assaulted that day to date 75 defendants
have been charged should the capitol
building have been locked down as a
crime scene that would have essentially
stopped the certification so i think
leadership wanted to ensure that look
let's collect as much evidence as we can
but we have to show the public
that
this process hasn't been deterred
approximately 165 individuals have
pleaded guilty among them the so-called
q anon shaman adam johnson and robert
scott palmer who pleaded guilty to
assaulting officers with a dangerous
weapon and was sentenced to more than
five years in prison the toughest
sentence yet the fbi is still asking for
the public's help to identify the pipe
bomber who left viable devices at the
republican and democratic party
headquarters if those devices went off
you go from a terrible situation to a
terrible situation on steroids
and another 350 believed to have
committed violent acts on capitol
grounds so are we years out from seeing
the end of these cases it would not
surprise me if there's cases charged in
2022 or 2023
and while the justice department has
brought a range of charges including
conspiracy and obstruction it has
stopped short of sedition among those
serious crimes tomorrow attorney general
garland will provide an update on the
department's efforts to get
accountability for january 6. gail
catherine thank you that video is still
so difficult to watch thank you very
much